For this problem, we are to calculate the expected number of edges
in an Erdos-Renyi graph with 256 nodes and a success probability of 0.25.
But before we answer that question, I want to look at a simpler question
where we have 4 nodes and a success probability of 1.
In the case where the success probability is 1, every possible edge will be created.
And we'll have a complete graph. In the case of 4, we'll have 6 edges.
And we've already discussed that the number of edges in a clique with n nodes is n(n-1)/2.
To get the expected number of edges when pâ‰1,
we have to multiply the total number of possible edges by p.
And so, in the original problem, we have n is 256 times n-1 is 255 divided by 2
times p that is 0.25, which is 8160.